Our next question from student, MTRTMK, from Pakistan.
This student asks, "What are some good programming practices,
and how important is it to follow programming practices
used by professionals--things related to like
naming variables, commenting the code,
being consistent with the structure--things like that?"
So this is a great question.
There are definitely many things that people learn
as they get more experienced in programming.
We're focused, in this class, on learning the basic concepts--
on getting you able to write and understand short programs.
I'm trying to use good practices in most of the programs
and, hopefully, those will come across.
But people have different opinions about the right way to code things.
Some opinions are better than others.
I think, in most cases, the opinions that I have are reasonably good ones.
Most cases--not always. >>Most of the time--we hope.
And you'll develop your own style.
You'll develop your own experience
as you get more experience as a programmer--how you like to do things--
but there are conventions that it's useful to follow,
and part of the reason it's useful to follow conventions
is you want it so other programmers can understand your code.
And things like using lower case names--
using lower cased letters at the start of a variable name
are just conventions, and that's used to distinguish
variable names from other things you might see in a program.
There's no really good reason for that, but that's
a convention that most programmers follow,
and it's good for you to follow it too so
if other people need to read your code
they'll be able to the code as well.